des chants et de la danse pour la reine
un bref aperçu de la réalité illuée lors
d'un voyage dans les Territoires du
Nord-Ouest presque toutes les visites
royales au Canada en comporté un volet
autochtone
l'occasion parfois de rappeler à la
couronne les conséquences de l'héritage
colonial et pour la reine de les
reconnaître ne serait-ce que du bout des
lèvres
on lève-toi
[Musique]
la relation entre la couronne et les
autochtones et aussi complexes
qu'ensienne avant même la création du
Canada en 1867 les deux parties ont
signé des traités qui devaient d'établir
tes relations commerciales et
territoriales entre elles desentes pas
toujours respecter et qui ont dépossédé
les autochtones de leur territoire et de
leurs droits mais les traités ont
néanmoins jeté les masses de cette
relation ils sont encore vus comme un
outil important sans le traité ça se
peut que les métiers les premiers
nations sont éliminés complètement André
carrière vous un grand respect à la
couronne et la reine mais il estime que
même avec un pouvoir symbolique la
monarchie porte une partie de la
responsabilité des pensionnats pour
autochtones et des politiques
d'assimilation du gouvernement canadien
la couronne arrêté à le gourmande de
séjour pour la simulation et l'auteur
qu'ils ont fait
après les excuses du pape et du
gouvernement canadien c'est maintenant
au tour de la Couronne britannique
d'admettre cet or croit cette professeur
autochton de l'Université de l'Alberta
des excuses de la couronne avaient
d'ailleurs été réclamé en marge de la
plus récente des étoiles royales au
Canada de retour dans les Territoires du
Nord-Ouest le prince Charles est
toutefois pas allé aussi loin
Charles est désormais le roi est depuis
son arrivée sur le trône
se multiplie pour que la couronne
renonce sans équivoque à la doctrine de
la découverte un principe religieux
datant du 15e siècle qui justifiait la
colonisation alors que un nouveau ring
s'amorce l'espoir d'une relation
renouvelée et franche entre la couronne
et les autochtones du pays pointent à
l'horizon
pour amorcer cette nouvelle étape André
carrière lance une invitation et
souhaite que le souverain revienne
rapidement au Canada pour venir écouter
à qu'est-ce que c'est passé écoutez la
vérité de des pensionnats au cours
de cérémoniale sous Elisabeth II la
relation entre la Couronne britannique
et les Autochtones au Canada pourraient
prendre une autre dimension la main est
tendue les attentes sont grandes à
l'endroit du nouveau souverain ici
Mathieu Gohier Radio-Canada Edmonton